ramener les retraités retenir les
travailleurs expérimentés ça ne suffira
pas à pallier la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre au Québec c'est le constat de
l'Institut du Québec dans une étude qui
est publiée aujourd'hui avec nous un
embraham il est économiste directrice
générale de l'Institut du Québec bonsoir
madame brame bonsoir c'est important
quand même de démystifier toutes sortes
de mythes autour de ça toutes sortes de
discours qu'on a entendu aussi mais ce
qu'on comprend c'est que c'est
démographique c'est mathématique on y
arrivera pas en courtisan seulement les
années pour qu'il retourne au travail
c'est ça certains dans le contexte de
pénurie de manœuvre dans lequel on est
on a entendu plusieurs solutions
notamment celle de retenir les
travailleurs un petit peu plus longtemps
au travail mais ce qu'on voit c'est que
le nombre potentiel de personnes qu'on
pourrait convaincre de rester au travail
un petit peu plus longtemps il est plus
limité que ce qu'on pense donc et ça
c'est parce que il y a beaucoup de
baby-boomers qui ont déjà quitté le
marché du travail donc si on regarde les
60 à 69 ans
qui est le groupe qui est souvent visé
par les mesures d'allongement de
carrière mais ce groupe là dans les 10
prochaines années il va diminuer de
105.000 personnes alors que les 10
dernières années il avait augmenté de
250 000 personnes ce que ça fait c'est
que les efforts qu'on va mettre
aujourd'hui vont être beaucoup moins
payants donc si aujourd'hui on avait le
même taux de participation des 60-69 ans
que l'Ontario on ajouterait
86000 personnes sur le marché du travail
alors que si on le faisait en 2032 ce
serait seulement 37000 personnes de plus
qu'on ajouterait qu'on comprend en fait
c'est que le bassin de travailleurs
expérimenté au travail potentiel va se
réduire parce qu'il vieillissent aussi
évidemment et puisque vous parliez de
toute participation pour mieux
comprendre ce que vous venez d'expliquer
on a un graphique qui le montre assez
bien ça c'est le taux d'activité
justement des 60 69 ans quand on regarde
le Japon on se dit que le Québec quand
on est très très loin c'est 62 et demi
pour cent à ce moment là Ontario 46%
donc de cette tranche d'âge qui est
active sur le marché du travail ça peut
prendre le même pourcentage pour les
États-Unis un peu moins pour le Canada
et le Québec on est à 39 %. il y a quand
même un écart assez important avec la
province voisine à peu près 7 points
pourcentage est-ce que vous nous dites
c'est que si on rattrapait le taux
d'activité de l'Ontario on gagnerait oui
quand même un bon bassin de main
d'oeuvre mais qui serait qui serait
rétrécirait si on veut au cours des
années c'est ça exactement même si le
bassin serait rétrécit qu'on se compare
à l'international on voit qu'il y a de
la place à l'amélioration et donc notre
taux participation est plus faible que
d'autres pays c'est vrai que c'est
difficile parfois de se comparer à des
pays qui ont des institutions
différentes une culture différente mais
l'Ontario nos voisins avec qui on est
parfois en compétition pour les
investissements pour les travailleurs
mais on peut voir qu'il y a quand même
un écart de toute participation pour ce
groupe d'achat un autre endroit où il y
a vraiment de la place à l'amélioration
c'est les femmes
on le voit le taux de participation des
femmes et alors qu'il est excellent pour
les Québécoises plus jeunes 25 à 24 ans
on a le taux de participation le plus
élevé au Canada la D55 ans s'a plonge et
les cas entre les hommes et les femmes
il est important est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on a une idée pourquoi ou du moins
comment régler ou améliorer ce bilan là
c'est sûr que pour combler ces écarts
dont on vient de parler il faut
comprendre que la décision de la prise
de la retraite c'est elle est
multidimensionnelle on l'a souvent
considéré seulement du point de vue
financier avec des incitatifs fiscaux
par exemple mais si on regarde la
littérature on voit que il y a très peu
d'indications que des incitatifs fiscaux
seuls pourraient renverser la tendance
nous on a identifié près d'une dizaine
de facteurs qui influencent cette
décision de prise à la retraite donc oui
il y a des aspects financiers combien
j'ai d'épargne est-ce que j'ai des
obligations financières comme une
hypothèque mon régime de retraite mais
aussi mon état de santé mon niveau de
scolarité mes obligations familiales
travailleurs de 1969 ans sont de plus en
plus nombreux à devoir aussi prendre
soin d'un parent plus âgés et donc
doivent faire cette conciliation travail
famille donc il y a plusieurs éléments
qui sont pris en compte lorsqu'on prend
cette décision et c'est pas seulement
les institutifs financiers qui justement
parce qu'en campagne électorale on a
beaucoup insisté là-dessus on a présenté
plusieurs propositions fiscaux est-ce
que vous êtes en train de nous dire que
cette solution là ne fonctionne
carrément pas on est capable quand même
de convaincre certains d'entre eux de
revenir au travail grâce à ça mais
aujourd'hui au Québec le principal outil
c'est le crédit d'impôt pour
prolongation de carrière qui joue un
rôle les études les études d'impact qui
ont été faites sur ce crédit d'impôt là
montre que c'est sûr que il pourrait
être mieux ciblé parce que présentement
ils visent tous les travailleurs et donc
il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
seraient restées au travail de toute
façon qui vont toucher ce crédit-là donc
est-ce que ça a vraiment un impact sur
le taux de participation peut-être pas
tant que ça puis aussi il faut retenir
que la manière dont ces structuré fait
que
principalement les travailleurs moins
bien rémunérés puisqu'il il diminue
progressivement avant 70 000 dollars
donc pour retenir les travailleurs plus
qualifiés c'est pas un outil qui
pourrait fonctionner on doit
s'intéresser d'ailleurs aussi au
parcours des 40 ans et plus vous dites
dans votre étude pourquoi mais ce qu'on
voit c'est que la décision de la prise
de la retraite elle se prend longtemps à
l'avance on épargne en planifie avec son
conjoint par exemple quand est-ce qu'on
veut prendre la retraite et donc il faut
aussi lorsqu'on met en place des mesures
pour allonger les carrières il faut
prendre en compte que ça n'aura pas un
effet immédiat ça aura peut-être un
effet sur les générations plus jeunes
qui sont en train maintenant de
réfléchir et de planifier leur retraite
donc ce qu'on comprend c'est que les
travailleurs expérimentés effectivement
c'est une solution pas miracle mais
partielle à ce problème de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre très clair vous
explications merci beaucoup d'avoir été
là madame RAM merci à vous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]